this is the specialized turbo it's the
company's first electric bike and while
it's been on sale in Europe for the past
year it's top speed was too high for us
roads until now unlike every other
e-bike out there it doesn't look like a
failed high school science experiment or
a prop reject from Blade Runner there's
no throttle all you do is pedal normally
and it goes faster with only three or
four pumps you're up in over 15 miles
per hour house within that massive down
tube is a 342 watt hour battery pack
that power is a 250 watt hub mounted
rear motor that's enough juice to keep
you cranking away for close to an hour
which gets you up to a limited top speed
of 27 miles per hour and at 50 pounds
you need the extra get up the battery is
removable takes a few hours to charge
but the rest of the bike is pretty much
sealed up meaning modifications are out
of the question at fifty nine hundred
dollars it's hardly a bargain but for
anyone looking for a two-wheeled Joyride
that doesn't involve a motorcycle
license there are worse ways to spend
your disposable income just avoid
carrying it up the stairs